well
[Music]
cata greets you cristian cásseres with his
news now radio station in spanish
the woman accused of killing her two
children in henderson was extradited to las
vegas who ranges from 33 years old was
arrested in arizona on wednesday
night  Authorities said she
admitted to taking the lives of her
two young children, ages 1 and 4. The
children were found dead
inside a residence located on
Jeppesen and Sunset on Monday night,
and for sports fans, the Gold Cup has
already entered into  their knockout phase on
saturday sunday the quarterfinals will be played
is qatar and el salvador
will face each other on saturday while
mexico and honduras will play after that
match on sunday costa rica will
face canada and the usa will compete
against jamaica remember that the
gold cup final will be here in las vegas
on august 1st and the city of
north las pegas will host a
back to school fair this saturday on  event
will be from 9 am to 1 pm
at the cake branch amphitheater there will be
free school supplies for
students and teachers
the first 2500 to attend will receive
a completely free backpack
students will also be able to receive the
required immunizations to start the
school year and  do not put away the umbrella
we will still have a minimal chance of
rain in the region for this Friday we will
reach 106 degrees in
temperatures and with more humidity than
normal the chances of storms will return
for the next few days since we
are in the middle of the
monsoon season I am a Christian  cásseres with his
previous
news now in Spanish good day
[Music]